what is up everybody it's annamac here
from
anime outbroar and today i will be
delving
into the latest events of the epic black
clover story
and let me tell you things just got even
crazier the identity of asta's mom
appears to have been conclusively
confirmed
and the conclusion of asta's fight with
his own devil gave us
a truly heartwarming moment but we
didn't get to enjoy the feels for long
because asta and his devil must now face
a much
greater challenge so let's get into it
if you enjoy our black clover content
and you want us to keep it going
please leave a like and drop a comment
down below
i know you might think that it doesn't
matter but leaving a like and commenting
actually helps us out a lot because it
tells youtube to recommend our video to
more people
and don't forget that you can also
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to be notified whenever we upload
a new black clover video finally this
video will of course contain
black clover manga spoilers we are
tackling the latest developments
in the story so please proceed with
caution you have been
warned now in my last black global
review
i speculated that the fight between
austin liba would not
end yet and i thought that there would
still be more drama to come before the
two of them
finally made peace it turns out that i
was totally wrong because the battle
really did end
on the final page of the previous
chapter using his incredible physical
abilities
asta managed to overcome liba and pin
him down
using yami's katana as a result liba was
bound by magical chains and
forced down on his knees knocked
congratulates asta
and he explains that since asta defeated
his devil in a duel he can now
force the devil into a contract that
favors
osta essentially the devil is now
compelled to
submit to asta and to serve as his
subordinate
he has no right to refuse and he must
follow
asta's orders whatever they may be
presumably
if the devil had won the duel then the
terms of the contract would have been
reversed and asta would have been the
one who has to be subordinate
to liba nacht tells asta that forcing
his devil into a submissive position
is the best way for asta to get stronger
quickly
and of course they need him to get as
strong as possible as soon as possible
because
time is running out the lives of yami
and william hang in the balance
as well as the lives of like 90 percent
of the world's population
so yeah doing what noct is suggesting
would be the most pragmatic thing to do
but we all know our boy asta and we know
that he
isn't about to enslave liba for his own
gain
so instead of asking the devil to submit
asta asks him to be his friend
liba is shocked and knocked's face when
he hears us to say this
is absolutely hilarious knox like
bruh this guy can't be this naive
but of course asta insists and he tells
the devil that he wants them to be
equal partners so this means that they
will enter
into a contract on equal terms
as he already made clear earlier asta
is extremely grateful to his anti-magic
devil for allowing him to use anti-magic
all this time including those critical
times when he needed to use the power to
save his friends and loved ones from
harm
asta is determined to show his gratitude
by befriending the devil
and learning more about him and that
means that any contract that they enter
into
must be equally beneficial for both
parties
noct once again warns asta against this
explaining that there is no guarantee
that the devil will actually follow his
orders
and that means that this type of
contract could end up backfiring on asta
a devil is dangerous and unpredictable
and deciding to trust one of them is a
massive risk
that's actually funny because i feel the
same way about being friends with
nakstaku
however asta then says something
interesting and something
very important the main reason why i
thought that the battle between asta and
liba would go on for longer was because
i couldn't believe that asta would be
able to defeat
a devil so easily devils are extremely
powerful beings
and even someone with incredible
physical power like asta
is at a massive disadvantage when facing
off against the devil
but osta offers an explanation as to
why he was able to win so quickly the
anti-magic devil
was clearly holding back and he never
had any real intention of killing
or seriously injuring asta that is why
asta was able to win and it is also why
asta trusts that the devil
is a good person if the devil really
wanted to hurt
asta he could have done it but he
refused to do so
the devil was holding back even at the
cost of his own
potential enslavement for that reason
asta doesn't want this contract to be a
contract of subordination
rather he wants it to be a contract of
friendship
when he hears this gimodello is like man
that guy
really is stupid and knocked just pauses
for a second before saying
yup i feel like throughout this entire
conversation knocked was internally face
bombing over and over again
but asta is asta and we know that he
would never agree to enslave anyone
not even a devil after everything that
asta has had to go through in terms of
discrimination and after everything that
the devil's power has allowed him to
achieve
asta was always going to ask the devil
to work together
as a team in fact asta mentions to liba
that they now have
a common enemy lucifer and dante
so it actually makes perfect sense for
the two of them to work together
and as the now unchained leaver
continues to kneel before asta
asta holds out his hand and invites
lieber to stand
up even liba has to agree that asta is a
total idiot
but he also realizes that meeting asta
may have been
fate as asta asks the devil for his name
liba recalls that lichita had once asked
him that very same question
soon after she had first rescued him
from the forest
when the devil replied that he didn't
actually have a name
it was lychita who gave him his name
liebe
and that actually makes sense why would
the other devils have fearsome names
like
lucifer and zagred and magikula but liba
has a name that means
love in german the fact that his name
was given to him by his adoptive mother
makes a lot more sense she was a loving
person and she loved him as her own son
so she named him liba love in that
moment liba confirms that asta
is indeed leechita's child and he stands
up
and shakes osta's hand as he does this
liba also reveals his name and in the
very next moment
the contract between them is sealed on
equal terms and
asta's right arm returns it is still a
demonic arm made up of the devil's
darkness
but at least asta can use it again man
this was such an epic and such a
heartwarming moment
for so long i wondered who asta's devil
was
where he came from and what his true
intentions were
seeing him turn out to be asta's
long-lost adoptive brother
was definitely a surprise but a good one
asta will now get a chance to learn
about his mother and who she was
from liba and that is really cool
because she was clearly a loving and
kind woman
but a woman whom asta never got the
chance to know
she is presumably dead now and i say
presumably because in black clover
characters we thought were dead tend to
come back to life
but even though she is dead she lives on
in liebe's heart and he will be able to
share his memories
of her with asta at the same time
liba will get a chance to repay
lichita's kindness by helping her other
son
osta and together they will be able to
avenge her by taking down
lucifer it's perfect this is both
emotional and extremely hype at the same
time
and seeing asta and liba shake hands and
agreed to work together
was really something special but that is
not where this chapter ends
knocked then steps in and says that the
contract has been made
even though he's never seen this type of
equal contract between a devil
and a human nevertheless noct doesn't
waste any time dwelling on the deep
philosophical meaning
of this event he explains that the
contract ritual was just the first step
of asta's training and now austen liba
must take their training to the next
level the real test for asta and liba
will be to try and work together to
defeat
noct himself and as he explains their
next
task to them noct is engulfed by his
demonic
darkness he suddenly manifests what we
can assume
is his full power devil form it is
definitely a cool looking devil form and
it's safe to say that knocked is about
to test the limits of asta
and liba's resolve and that is how this
fast-paced and info-packed chapter ends
the battle between austin and liba
really is over
and their contract has been made on
equal terms
the two of them will now work together
as a team
and together they will get a chance to
honor their mother's memory
but at the same time their training is
not over yet
in fact the main part of their training
has only just begun
they must now face a much more
experienced
devil magic user and judging by what we
know about
knocked so far i don't think that he is
about to go easy
on asta and liba i loved the brotherly
bonding between osta and leva
and i can't wait to see what new powers
and abilities they will unlock
now that they are working together asta
was already strong when he was just
using a fragment of liba's anti-magic
power
so i am absolutely stoked to find out
everything that the two of them are
going to be able to do
now with that said i am also looking
forward to learning more about
knocked devil and about his shadow magic
after all he is the vice captain of the
black bulls
he is a spymaster and an expert devil
user
but we still don't know the full extent
of his power not even
close if tabitha decides to show us asta
and liba versus knocked
in detail instead of say just skipping
to something else in the next chapter
then we can look forward to learning a
lot more about both
shadow magic and anti-magic i am so
excited because both of these powers
seem to be some of the strongest and
most useful abilities
in all of black clover let me know what
you guys think
did you enjoy the bonding between asta
and liba as much as i did
and what do you think noct still has
planned for the two of them
how much stronger is asta now going to
become
and will it be enough to save yami don't
forget to leave your input
down in the comments below if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more black lover content right here on
the channel
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help and if you're new to
anime pro
or maybe you just haven't subscribed
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications
even though it's annoying you really
have to go through the trouble of
hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all if you don't do that you're gonna
miss a ton of our videos even if you are
subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
a big thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons who make videos like this
one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma and
liam thompson disciples
of lord tuigo himself and i can't forget
our
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
above
all other clans including ingrata
the world acquired respect pate hepha
jonathan king rathuing deora red-haired
raven
emperor otaku thomas jones kin mano
admirath
and chris torley finally thank you to
all of our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
nothing but a fan
steelers anatoly kazatsky cricket xp joe
stanton
very gucci jessica califond alicia octor
hinokami in water bonnie parks florian
joanne garcia
mcshamus deadly saint and high school
dxd73
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you